I've mentioned overfitting before,
but I haven't yet defined it.
Before we could define it, and
I could give you an example,
we needed to have a definition of error.
Let me now show you what I mean.
Let's consider parameterized polynomial
models where we can, one at a time, add
additional factors, like x, x squared,
x cubed, x to the fourth, and so on.
Let's create a graph where we
have along the horizontal access
degrees of freedom, or d,
the degree of our polynomial.
And vertically here,
we'll have the error of our model.
So let's measure error as we
increase d on our training set.
So when d is smallest,
our error is greatest.
And as we increase d,
our error drops and drops and drops.
In other words, we're fitting
the data in sample better and better.
When finally we get to N, where we
have as many parameters in our model
as we do have items in our data set,
our error gets all the way down to zero.
This is in sample error.
Now, let's add a similar line for
out of sample error.
Remember that we expect our
out of sample error to always
be greater than or
equal to in sample error.
The curve will look something like this.
It'll start out at maximum error, about
the same as our in sample line, and
as we go down,
we begin to diverge like this.
Now in this region
both our in sample and
out of sample errors
are still decreasing, but
eventually we'll reach a point where
our out of sample begins to increase.
In fact it may increase strongly.
In this area, as we increase degrees
of freedom, our in sample error is
decreasing, but
our out of sample error is increasing.
And that's how we define overfitting.
This is the region where
overfitting is occurring.
So, let me state that again.
In sample error is decreasing,
out of sample error is increasing.
And we have those two together,
it's over fitting.